Okay
for thousands of years. The central
narrative which has guided human behavior.
What's the beliefs that are world rest
of the center of the Cosmos designed
specifically for our
human story to unfold.
At the dawn of the Copernican revolution,
this worldview came crashing down to
earth and we now struggle to find meaning
in a world that no longer explains
itself before these discoveries of our
scientific age.
It was the stories we told that guided
US provided a reason for why we are here,
where we came from and what
happens once we are gone.
It is often thought that a culture is
mythology indicates the striving and self
examination of that culture.
What do the stories we tell the day say
about who we are, how we see the world,
and how we view our place in the cosmos?
What does it say about the drastic
change of our worldview and the last 100
years when our most popular and perhaps
only myth we have left is the myth that
has become the most enduring,
expressive and consummate metaphor for
our current crisis in meaning the myth
that stands for every
conceivable human failing.
The Myth of the Zombie
tragedy was one of the most noble
art forms of Ancient Greece.
It was common for the
suffering of characters like
Oedipus to be preordained by
fate, fate that even the gods
were incapable of altering.
One of the key themes of stories like
the Oedipus cycle was his redemption.
That all his suffering was not in vain,
that it had purpose and meaning.
Tragedy dignifies the events of
suffering by giving them significance.
The Zombie apocalypse is the anti tragedy.
It immerses us in a story
and denies US closure.
Most Zombie stories in the same way
that is if they ended all the camera
ambiguously fades away.
As we realize that there is no
redemption for the survivors.
No silver bullet, no stake in the heart,
no action the protagonist can take,
which will lead to the
salvation of their world.
Most cultural interpretations of the
Zombie begin with the premise that in some
pivotal way zombies are us.
The are the fictionally distorted
self-reflected version of modern man.
Zombies do represent us,
but more specifically,
they represent the deterioration of
our uniquely human ability to make and
sustain meaning in our lives.
Monsters are not a new phenomenon,
though their names and faces
have changed throughout time.
They all seem to stand to some degree
for the dark and instinctual drives of
human nature.
The most pervasive and consistent monster
of the 20th century was the alien,
a perfect representation of our
20th century fear of the foreigner.
At the height of our conflict
with the Soviet Union,
extinction by a foreign invader was at
the forefront of everyone's mind and it
became one of the most
enduring trends in pop culture.
Many things have changed in our post
Cold War and new monster has emerged a
monster with traits never seen before.
They aren't mute or reticent. They simply
have no language. They don't transmit,
just have conversation. They do
the opposite. They communicate.
They're in comedic ability.
The most common reason we refer to someone
as a Zombie is that he doesn't seem
fully conscious.
He's not aware of himself.
He does not notice the
world go by the spoken word.
The ability to think,
strive and urine is what makes us human.
Clear and distinct.
Intellectual perception is with stands
at the center of the mind's ability to
recognize and reflect back on itself.
This is the individual's awareness
of himself, his existence,
his capacity to think and therefore
to be the lack of an interior.
Reality means that the Zombie
cannot connect to the world.
It cannot affirm its own realness and
it cannot affirm the realness of its
environment.
Zombies do not have layers,
ness, coffins, castles or caves.
They do not retreat anywhere.
As the sun breaks the horizon,
zombies drift.
There is nothing whatsoever about a Zombie
that appears to belong to this world.
There's a crucial difference
between a house and a home.
A house is simply a structure we inhabit.
A home is transforming that structure
into a place where we truly feel like we
belong at a greater level.
The culture we live in is meant
to provide that sense of home,
of belonging to a place into a people.
This is why it can be deeply distressing
to experience something like culture
shock.
Losing that feeling of at
homeness undermines the way
we make sense of the world
while it has beneficial to travel and
learn about new cultures and new ways of
life. When this sense of loss
happens within our own society,
when we our culture shocked
within our own culture,
suddenly there was no
place for us to retreat.
We cannot return home because there's
no home to return to that sense of
connectedness with our
environment is lost. Alienation,
depression and anxiety soon follow it
is not so much a sense of fear but of
horror like the feeling when would have,
if they were experiencing a slow and
inescapable descent into madness.
What better way to capture that feeling
than with a monster that is constantly
decaying but never dies?
Walkers,
flesh eaters dead on dead
to name something is to
accept and become aware of it
in stories of vampires,
werewolves or monsters of every kind.
As soon as you come to grips with
what you are facing, you can fight it.
Naming the monsters,
what guides the actions of the
protagonist to name the Zombie brings no
empowerment.
Just despair.
Killing a Zombie does nothing to solve
the larger conflict that you are facing.
Even in the few exceptions where the
survivors do call the Zombie by name,
it is done in a way that
simply reemphasizes the
hopelessness of their situation.
Their name is not spoken with awe or
reverence because there is nothing
supernatural about a Zombie.
They have no new Munis or magical quality,
no mysterious backstory surrounding them.
That is what makes the
Zombie a monster of nihilism.
The appear for no reason as a seemingly
self evident and inevitable consequence
of our modern sensibilities.
If the world we live in is
fundamentally without meaning.
Why would the end of that
world need to explain itself
instead of the process of
assimilating food for energy?
The Zombie is insatiable zombies
like the properties of mine.
We think fundamentally human,
yet they want to acquire mind.
In the most literal sense,
the brain is a symbol for intelligibility.
The devouring of the brain indicates the
devouring of that intelligibility and
all it affords.
The fact that the brain is driving the
consumption of brain is a deeply complex
symbolic occurrence.
Culture is devouring culture.
Mind is devouring mind.
Humanness is devouring humanness.
This tells us that the Zombie is not
an external threat but an internal one.
The Zombie craze with such singularity
of purpose that this craving becomes its
nature. It will feed itself
for as long as it is able,
but it does not incorporate
or gain nourishment from
anything that it consumes.
It is constantly filling
but never gets full.
What does our modern world desire
to consume more than anything else?
Information and connectivity.
We feel that by devouring each other's
minds we can somehow regain that sense of
connectedness to the people around us,
but it never works.
We never gain nourishment and our
craving never subsides as brain is eating
brain.
The instrument we use to make meaning
in the world is devouring itself,
the gathering,
an incredibly large numbers,
but these gatherings have
no aim and no purpose.
There is no history between any of them.
There is no structure,
no culture and no cooperation
or organization of any kind.
They're surrounded by each other but
somehow remain in total isolation.
Lacking the ability to
reach out to one another.
To feel alone in a crowd full of
people is a very modern problem.
We have always been
surrounded by strangers,
but they have never been
as strange as they are now.
We must be able to interact with
something in order to understand it and
objective,
factual understanding of something is
not the same as an intimate and deeply
personal knowing we feel and interact
with the world around us by touching the
around us.
The world in turn touches us,
makes us feel that we're a part of it.
The Zombie has a cold,
purely objective
interaction with the world.
It no longer feels it has one purpose
in anything else is relegated to
meaninglessness.
When a person's grasp
of reality is slipping,
we see that they are losing touch
because touch is how we make sense of the
world. The objects we have
handled, the emotions we have felt,
the intimate relationships we have held.
These are the things we
take to be most real.
The Zombie represents a crisis
of intimacy. Every person
is a Zombie and waiting.
It's contact with the world spreads.
It's conditioned like a plague.
The more we encountered
the unfeeling mess,
the more we become the unfeeling mass.
Our modern world discourages contact in
all its forms and treating everyone like
a stranger is the only
way to avoid infection.
We are surrounded in yet stranded,
inundated,
well utterly alone
in cities all around the world.
A strange sort of ritual
enact may is taking place.
Zombie walks represent a form
of mystical participation,
a return to primitive psychology in
which we find no trace of the concept of
individuality.
Instead we find a collective relationship
which French ethnologist levy broke
called participation mystique.
It is described as a psychological
connection in which the subject could not
clearly distinguish himself from
an external situation, your object,
the form of partial identity,
which the individual is bound to.
Very similar to what we call mob
mentality. At one of these Zombie walks,
there was an emergency situation and a
doctor was trying to get help from one of
the participants, but that person
would only respond as a Zombie.
The doctor is trying to get
them to realize that this
is the real world and this
person needs help,
but they refuse to break character.
Their commitment to the role,
which day point of possession
we tell ourselves
we had a walking dead.